while shooting a video my cameraman's i
don't know why i'm smiling because
this is actually quite serious but while
shooting a video my cameraman's finger
got chopped
in half actually chopped in half by a
device
known as a jib it creates shots like
this
or like this and i've come up
with a pretty innovative highly
technologically advanced prosthetic
that he's always wanted with a big twist
so you're gonna have to wait right till
the end of this video
very fragile
ten days off youtube felt like a day i
had great intentions of becoming
a yoga spirit in the himalayas or trail
runner
through the cedarburg but in all honesty
yeah actually you know what
wait can you dip your finger in it take
it off and dip your finger in it and
then go
ow but like
ow like more give it more you see
that right there would have been the
perfect clickbait
image but i'm new to this whole vlogging
thing this is only vlog six
and i promise i'm i'm not going to be
doing
clickbait anymore so does that mean
there's not going to be any more
like clickbaity thumbnails
yes in all honesty peeps
peeps just aren't digging but that
definitely
does not mean you're not going to be in
the vlog
because if you've seen the comments you
have clearly become the star
so i spontaneously decided to come up
with an idea to
ultimately find out who the real true
star of the show is you've all seen a
game show
10 basic questions posted by a host and
the first one to press the bell
gets to answer the question you
understand
yeah all right this video is brought to
you by storyblocks
they're a big supporter of my channel he
also helped me by providing motion
graphics templates
and stock footage but we'll talk about
that later
more importantly where is our host i
don't know maybe we have to tap on our
bells a few times
sorry sorry sorry uh welcome to this
week's episode
or actually probably the only episode of
so you think you're a star question
what sort of animal is walt disney's
dumbo
what date did you get engaged 3rd of
october
where was the fortune cookie inventory
china japan from
united states of america what's the
capital of kenya in africa
nairobi what is the most common color of
toilet paper in france
brown wrong pink
what day of the week does the trash get
taken out at your house
tuesdays jesus it's illegal in texas to
put what
on your neighbor's cow spread it
you enter the contest to find his own
look alike
and came third charlie chaplin
who's the most followed person on
instagram
final question what is the connective
noun for a group of unicorns
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
losing so you think you're a star hit me
pretty deep which means i'm in the need
of a huge dopamine kick and no i'm not
talking about drugs i'm talking about
something far better
surfing we still got around about four
hours until
jurgen gets home which means
i'm gonna go surfing for the first time
in six months
it's the possibility to
ride an unpredictable bump
created by the earth riding
something that you have no control over
not cool gopro
just as i did a burial aerial
triple loop a360 horizontal flip
basically it filled up with water
and on the box it says waterproof
now no one's going to believe that i
actually did this maneuver so i'm going
to have to recreate it with this
personalized miniature surfer
i took off on the perfect wave let me
get a better angle
to the lip and did something like this
and landed it except i had a smile on my
face
i'm on my way to surprise jurgen you
know with the
finger incident in addition to what's in
this mysterious case
i got him an even bigger surprise
the actual jerk that chopped off his
middle finger not just one middle finger
both middle fingers
you see what just happened there
this is a safety pin it ensures that
that doesn't happen jurgen's finger was
in there
the safety pin wasn't in guillotine
finger off blood
the exciting surprise is i bought it for
him
i tracked it down and i'm giving it to
him as a gift
where he can choose to chainsaw it into
pieces
or uh what else what else could you do
with it
dude come outside your house in 60
seconds
this is crazy i can't believe it
i got it for you it's yours dude this is
like
the most amazing present this made my
career
insane so just just to give you some
perspective so i'm sitting here
watching the playback from the shot and
jurgen's finger
is poking through that hole right there
and
down guillotines that entire amount of
weight and just
chops his finger in half but this this
isn't the gift
this is just uh actually you know what
let's go inside
[Music]
we were shooting a music video so we had
arranged gear
we went to a gear house and jurgen
looked
at the jib and said to me oh yeah
that's the job that chopped my middle
finger in half
three months ago fast forward seven
hours and
his other middle finger gets chopped in
half by the same chip
now how does this happen first of all
you don't know
how ridiculous it is to work with dan
sometimes i look down on my fingers
and i realize how quick things can
happen
all of a sudden you meet all of a
sardine
uh what do you mean like my tattoo
bro what the hell is that so i was with
my friend
and recently new intern casey in
brussels belgium for one night
where a fan approached casey offering
him a tattoo on the spot
casey cleverly declined the offer but i
love [ __ ] like that so i was like
i'm dumb with absolutely no idea of what
i wanted
until a little birdie on my shoulder
reminded me of why i say
oliver sardine instead of all of a
sudden
and in the least deep description here
sardines represent fortune
or the promise of better days to come
when things suddenly happen
for the better or worse i like the
reminder that it's part of the process
sudden spontaneous or sardine
experiences
should be greeted with open arms because
they can do real good for you too
so all of a sudden i found myself
sitting in a very makeshift studio set
up backstage at some convention in
brussels
getting the exact thing tattooed on my
shoulder
good yeah he's not good
he's not good there we go
[Music]
so it looks great man all i'm thinking
about
is what is in that box if you think back
to the very first
thing you said you would replace your
middle finger with
what was it oh my god there is nowhere
brew wait it's okay
not one but two prosthetic
fingers what you first asked me for
but you actually got the flatty beer
bottle opener
[Music]
and the second i gave you one with a usb
drive
legend
this is so cool that's cracker pack a
cold one yes
a ice cold one nine alcoholic
[Music]
as i said before this is a sponsored
video it's brought to you by
storyblocks the cool thing about
storyblocks is that you don't have to
make signs like this
you can do way cooler ones i only work
with brands that have purpose value
which means that
i believe that they would add purpose to
you and in my case
i use storyblocks all the time i use
storyblocks for
every single video that i met especially
as you've seen and heard time and time
again with my immersion scrapbooking
storyblocks offers super affordable
subscriptions to unlimited downloads
to over one million assets so head over
to
www.storyblocks.com forward slash
dan mace which will be linked in the
description to sign up today
and while doing my second favorite thing
in the world brian
it's uh it's come the time to say
goodbye
goodbye to my house which is kind of
melancholic
so remember the whole seed map idea that
i had which
which we're still implementing and
working on and and that's going to come
up later but for now
i've created a facebook group called the
brew community to have open and honest
discussions with one another to be able
to interact with a seed map i really
wanted people to be able to speak to one
another
find like-minded people and really build
this community
of creatives and just people that that
feel
different and that want to create
awesome [ __ ]
so to join the facebook group go down
into the link in the description
one one more thing subscribe and and if
you do
you can turn on your notifications below
it'll send you a notification
as soon as i upload a video and other
than that
i think you already know this by now but
i'm gonna remind you again
don't forget you're awesome brew and
i'll see you next week
[Music]